uh i think our next
guest is using
the height of modern technology olly
panderid
from community energy south
is live streaming into us i believe so i
have no control over the technology the
wizards at the back will do it let's see
what happens
well welcome everybody
um it's it's a pleasure to be speaking
to you but it would have been more of a
pleasure if i've been up and suffer with
you all and um
it's it's actually an area where i
started my energy journey in suffolk
because i used to work for national grid
and i was responsible for their
community relations so
actually visiting parishes and
some of you may remember
brantford to twin stage
when national group were talking about
upgrading an overhead line that went
through your region
and
then obviously connected into sizewell
and it was my job to set up all the
parish meetings
and um and try and find them as well in
the dark and attend them so
um
so i spent quite a lot of time in
suffolk in all and um but it's what
started me really on the journey
about
on the community energy journey and
working with communities on their own
energy
and um
because
it occurred to me that at that stage in
early 2000s
that you know people really didn't know
much about where electricity came from
or how it got to them at their homes or
their communities
and we were on that journey during that
branford trimstead project
and um where it became very live with
big pylons coming through the
countryside and sizeworld power station
and what have you so
um so i'm grateful to suffer from that
and it's great to be able to
to be talking to you about community
energy and sort of showcasing
the wonderful
work that communities are doing across
the southeast of england
and hoping that we can stimulate that
within suffolk
so um
sort of run on 20 years i'm currently
the chief executive of community entry
south and i'll explain a little bit
about that
i'm also the co-founder of
a company called riding sunbeams which
is directly powering
um railways with renewable energy
um which is a very exciting journey to
be on and off i'll touch on that as well
i'm also a director of community energy
england and
um take that role very responsibly in in
linking up with the teamwork community
in england and i believe philip has been
here this morning and talking to you so
it may be an overlap on sort of the
national perspective but it's important
that we take that into account at the
moment with cop 26 and everything that's
going on
and and your interest to to decarbonize
as communities
and um i've also been the chair of the
greater brighton city region
energy panel which worked alongside the
water panel
um which fed into
to that part of the country's region
and all the leaders deciding on the
future of net zero and zero carbon so um
there's also some experience there and
i've worked in um
the local energy team at bays or the
department of energy and climate change
and um led on community energy as well
so
i've got a machine on my
phone that's going to move this light on
which is very
exciting
when it connects
yes it works
so i'll share the slides afterwards and
i'll just use them as a guide to go
through with you um i've got about 20
minutes and then we can hopefully have
some questions and i can get to speak to
some of you
um and hear from you so community entry
south we set up in 2013 there's an
umbrella group for the region
in the southeast of england and we set
up from a project that started in sussex
and i'll i'll go into that in a little
bit in a minute but we we trained up 12
community entry groups in 2011
over a year-long program which was
funded by the cabinet office
and those groups are still all up and
running at the moment and what happened
was during that process of
setting up those 12 community energy
groups
um we set up community south as a
representative group for the 12
and um
and sort of nine years on
here we still are and there are about 42
community energy groups in the south
east of england and we're currently
mentoring
14
startup groups
so what you've got you've got an
industry in the community energy sector
in the southeast
that has been operating for nearly 10
years
and are very advanced some groups have
real expertise
and then other groups are new and
they're all cooperatives or community
benefit societies and they work together
so our role in um and that's why i've
got to find the app again to move my
slide along
so our role in community and shout outs
is to is to basically act
as a voice for the sector and we feed
into community entry england
we also look at capacity building for
local and community energy groups
so hopefully we're a point of
for
groups wanting to start up and link up
with other more advanced community entry
groups
but we also work in innovation and new
business models which is a big part of
the community energy sector and and the
community energy center was really built
up particularly in rural areas
to look at innovation look at
that gap
that is needed in the energy market and
it's a very exciting market for young
people coming into it it's full of
innovation and needs to innovate
you know if there's a solar farm
in your neighboring community why on
earth can you buy the power directly
from that solar farm and and that needs
innovation and the energy market is
evolving and it's it's a really exciting
time for the energy market for young
people
in particular
not least because of cop 26 and the
government's zero strategy
but because of this innovation because
the energy market needs to be reinvented
to come to modern times and and our
young people coming through universities
are not going to stand for it so we know
we've got to adapt people want to use
renewable energy they don't want to use
something that's powered by coal or
you know or gas and what have you so
um so it's a really exciting stage to
come to
and our role we see that as a kind of
role in between communities and
innovators and getting business models
up and running
yeah
so um so a little bit of background um
of esco so if any of you know lewis
which is where i'm speaking from
is down on the south coast in sussex um
avasco set up in 2007 as a community
energy group
and um they have actually
um
been there's a one pound louis pound
note
the of esco's on um which is live
currency within the community this was a
five thousand pound note that um
the district council actually printed
off to invest
in a community energy scheme on a roof
but avasco started up in 2009
um when they put they put solar on
harvey's brewery roof on the depot roof
the part of his brewery who had a very
high energy usage for cooling and
for running the brewery
and the solar panels um there's about
100 kilowatts of solar panels
and it cost about 300 000 pounds at the
time and we went to the community in
lewes and raised a share offer under a
um community benefit society so people
could buy shares in the solar scheme
that powered the harvey's brewery
and they have those shares for 25 years
they're not transferable they are
redeemable
and
people get an interest between four and
seven percent on those shares at that
time
and um people are very proud of it and
actually a lot of people don't take
their interest they give it back to the
society to reinvest it in community
benefits and it meant that evasco can
actually employ a part-time employee
for 25 years
to manage this scheme and a whole host
of other schemes now but also
act as an energy advisor scheme to the
local district
and that's really important
so that's
why we set up community and south
because the uvasco model worked so well
and the phone was ringing all the time
in the ubescom office
asking from other community groups how
to do it
and actually there was one group that
beat
um
evasco tourette which was in suffolk at
the time on a school and john taylor can
remind me who that is later
but um but they were they were together
in the race so we set up communities out
because of ibesco and ebesco have um won
all sorts of international awards for
that work
sorry i'm just connecting my thing again
um so at the same time this is important
because i'll come back to it um
neighboring
the
town of babasco is a is a village called
barkum it's got 850 residents
and um
it's an energy bill last year
those residents combined
spent 1 000
1.5 million pounds on their energy in
the village
and that was all money that left the
economy
so we did a
rural community energy plan just for the
parish so we looked at the led lighting
we did home energy surveys
we did um where could community solar go
and all sorts of different work looking
at a hydro stream because it's got a
river
and all sorts and we did a very detailed
energy plan
for the rural community
and um and that's really important i
think for parishes and i know that alex
templeton is doing a workshop afterwards
and i think the parishes should discuss
that
um because it's really important to have
a plan for your community
and i'll come back to that in a little
while
so in 2018 2019 when we did our
mentoring of the new groups in sussex
this is what the map of community energy
looked like sort of five years on
so the green dots are the live community
energy groups the red dots are energy
champions working in those communities
to provide energy advice so one-to-one
energy advice bill checking and what
have you through the big energy saving
network and that's really important at
the moment because look what's happening
to the energy market
um there are energy companies
falling over themselves people aren't
registered for warm home discount you
know people need their hand holding with
this
and it's a really important part and at
the time we're also doing a faith and
power
work as well working with um
nepalese communities and other um
um
communities within the southeast just
talking about energy and that was really
exciting you really have a
an avid group because it's complicated
um okay and solar schools so
this is the top left hand shows a bar
chart the history of solar schools and
it just gives you a
an overview
so within an eight year period 84
community energy schools were developed
the first year was very complicated
and there were years um like 2016 was a
very high install date
because of the feed-in tariff you know
the the regulatory
um the
the um
the stimulators for the solar industry
was very high in 2016 so there were lots
of installs
and again in 2019 2018 2019
so um but really what this tells me is
that
in 2012 it seemed quite complicated to
do community energy but actually eight
years later
84 schools had communities solo on um
over four megawatts of power 60 000 kids
going to school
with solo that's owned and invested in
by the community and
that's really fundamental and
you know consider at the moment
how much um people have money in savings
accounts it's earning just
half a percent you know it could be
invested in local renewable energy
projects that could benefit local people
so you know community wealth and the
ability to be able to invest
into your own renewable energy
is a real asset and something that could
be really
developed fast
to try and get us to decarbonization
this is the face of community energy at
the moment so the gentleman in top right
hand corner is our current
community energy person of the year nick
krauss
and he's in his 80s he volunteers every
day for a community energy group he's
amazing
and a couple of years ago before kovidge
he invented a solar bike
where 5 000 kids at stem events went on
in a year um and in the bottom left hand
corner north kensington community energy
launched the scheme about a year and a
half ago
and they are the community that
neighbors graham fell
so um and you could have invested at
that time and got three percent
for their for their solar scheme going
on a community
um
building near to grenfell so that's very
exciting
so a little bit about the sector and the
community energy sector
we um community engineering and
undertake an annual report of the
community energy sector they have a 30
vision that they did a year a year ago
and they modeled a ten-fold increase in
the community energy sector and that's
really fundamental actually they said
that's an average 10 but it could go up
to 20 times larger
and um
with the ability to employ 8 700 jobs
you know it's a real it's a real change
there are now over 320 groups across
england
developing and owning solar farms to eat
projects to transport projects
it's a really good way of you know
moving the industry forward and taking
control
so community engineering and we work
alongside them they're based up in
sheffield philip is here
but um do sign up to them i'll give you
the details in this presentation and you
can link up with all the other groups
around the uk doing amazing projects
and there's a state of the sector report
this is
um statement sector report for 2020 and
it gives you all the detail and
background
into all the different projects the
community benefit the education projects
community transport
and energy efficiency and all the
the amazing groups that are doing this
so you're never alone when you want to
start up a project
there's always through community england
and community and shouts we can link you
up with other groups who are desperate
to share what they've learned and and
scale up
and there's a map of community energy
and you can see in norfolk and suffolk
we need more community energy groups and
there's a real ability for that
um i'll share these slides with
everybody but
there's a where to find support go to
the community entry england
website and there's all sorts of access
you can get and through
um john taylor at the greater southeast
energy however i know is here as well
and for those of you who like tweeting
and all sorts you know
do tweet community energy english
and um and you know join the page
so with community energy south we have a
monthly newsletter where we showcase
community energy projects and
and also we run a monthly webinar
webinar so we've just had one um
yesterday on ev car sharing
and um it's very exciting so please do
join up um on average we have about 120
people on each webinar every month and
it's a really good way of linking in
with other communities and new
communities and old so we've designed
that specifically for that
now
so
going back to our roots with mentoring
we actually with essex county council
originally we set up something called
community energy pathways which is a
mentoring program for new community
energy groups and we're running that
currently
in essex hampshire south house and
actually just starting off in surrey
county council as well
um and it's a really exciting program
that we put together
um it's based on communications you're
mapping all the communities and finding
out who now
which communities are interested in
community energy and then bringing them
together and taking them through a
training program
and we're having great results in in
hampshire in essex i'll show you in a
minute we've got eight groups now
established and raising funds through
the rural community energy fund and
supported by our mentoring team
and and that continues so
um and through the eastern new energy
project we can do that to a certain
extent in in south africa norfolk and um
but we're always there to to access that
so
so do get in contact about our pathways
now the importance of pathways and i i
just wanted to
show you this for those of you from the
local authority looking at net zero
is that you would have a local area
energy plan or strategy towards climate
change but what we need to do is grow
that network that community energy
network
from within a region
and there's a good reason for that and
that's it so we've done that in essex
this is the example from essex
where we've got saffron warden
colchester danbury south end
tollsbury debton braintree now all
established as community entry groups
and working together
within a framework and that's important
because essex county council can now go
to that network
and
with consultations or
or um or pass by them their strategy on
climate change and get them to work
together and then we can look at new
opportunities or more of a scale and a
framework position
and and that's important we've
established that in essex
hampshire south house national park and
they're now starting out in surrey as
well which means that all the the
networks that we've got already in
sussex
can now all work together as a network
and people can feed in and share best
practice so it's really connected from a
community perspective
right partnerships for the sector really
important
uk power networks is our best friend
um and that's important because they
supply power across the southeast
through and in the edn what they call
the eastern region
and their goals are very aligned with
the community energy sector
so
we support renewable energy and we
support vulnerable communities with
their energy and that's very aligned
with with the power networks
and
um
so the power networks and the gas
networks should really love community
energy and working with us and it's
really important from the connections
perspective as well
and um and also the water companies
should as well and the environment
agency
do a lot of pumping they require power
you know all of these things which
relate to a local community
are are important and should align so we
build partnerships
with community energy for the sector and
obviously work with
great southeast energy hub as well
and within the southeast region a lot of
you will be aware there's an energy
strategy that was developed between
um celeb the southeast lap
coaster capital and enterprise m3
which fed into a regional energy
strategy and community energy is
embedded in that which is very helpful
and then to take that to a really
up-to-date
line
we now have
the government's net zero strategy
and have a look at it from page 272
onwards and around there 262 to 280
there's a whole section on community
energy and the importance of driving the
community energy sector for net zero and
getting communities involved with this
whole agenda
i'll pass on to that but you'll see it
in my slides in brighton
we've established with the local
authority working with the community and
sector 10 pledges for tackling climate
change that includes building a kelp
forest
and the community energy sector have
come together to invest
with sussex wildlife trust to actually
invest in the kelp officer so
the community energy
has developed a community benefit fund
and we're investing that in the kelp
officer
took to build the kelp for us and to
create more carbon saving so it's very
circular um but
these ten pledges that were
pledged by the region
um includes zero emission fleets ev
charging points rewilding low carbon
housing
public buildings innovation lobbying the
government
and that's now embedded
at the regional level and that's really
important for the community energy
sector it means that we can thrive and
get the support of local authorities
keep on forgetting i've got the app
excuse me
uh so going back to that energy plan at
the very beginning um that we talked
about
um i'm just going to show you a project
that we've developed
called community where we've taken
the infant the energy plan that we did
in 2012 in this rural community of 800
homes
and then we've built a road map for that
community now to go to low carbon so to
come off oil 80 of the village uses oil
for heat
and every household now has its own plan
to come off oil
so what we're discovering
is that
some people in the village want to go to
s or c pumps now come off oil so and
this will i'm sure
interest a lot of you because i'm sure
a fair few of you are from rural
communities and use oil
so
a percentage of the village want to go
now of oil so we're capturing that
amount
we've got another group of the community
that would like to go by 2025 and those
that want to go by 2030. so what we're
doing is we're developing a plan
for that with uk power networks to also
reinforce the grid
for the community to take on electric
heating and electric cars
but also to work with the supply chain
so the supply chain
know
when they can focus on that one
community and what efficiencies there
are
for them to focus on that one community
so it's a it's a plan a road map for a
rural community to go to net zero
and um it's been great that we've been
working with uk power networks on that
and they realized the benefit of it for
for their future reinforcement program
there's some information about the
village but typically rural villages
have much higher energy output and like
i said this one with about 600 homes
there they spend 1.5 million a year on
powering their community on energy which
leaves the economy now we want to try
and keep that money in the economy
so one big issue that we're working out
with this community project and rural
community is how do we finance it how do
we some people have the money in the
bank they'll just do it
from savings you know the pioneers
um and now there's a government one
isn't there for 5 000 pounds
but in rural communities
heat pumps are generally up to about 12
000 pounds at the moment
so how do we bridge that gap
and um
there's something really brilliant as
being developed by the industry which is
community municipal bonds
where you combine
pwlb funding with community finance and
community energy and that's really
important but we're also
working with the credit union banks
and a company called
lendology who are doing low interest
loans for retrofits and that's something
we really need to push forward you know
we need to find
these solutions
for rural communities to to be able to
lend money at low rates
so that they can do
insulation
and
transition to low carbon heating it's 30
of the carbon for rural communities on
average
so and if we can find a way for those
communities to afford it
we can get the supply chain working as
well and that's really important
to get local jobs people skilled up and
working locally and keeping the money in
the economy
right so another innovation that
community and shouts have done
is um with riding sunbeams so one of our
community energy groups back in 2012 you
know mentoring program said why can't we
just power the railways
um so we've developed um a program
called riding sunbeams and we're
currently working with a community group
down in east sussex to connect the first
multi-megawatt solar park to the railway
which will directly connect it and
create an annual community benefit fund
and that's very exciting and it's it's a
global changer really you know if we
want to
decarbonize we need to get people
towards public transport and moving in a
better way
out of diesel and fuel cars and we are
going to have to go there at some point
in the next decade
and our transport systems have got to
improve and got to be run and
decarbonized as well it's the england's
the uk's highest energy user is the
railways
but if you travel by train
it's a massive um
decarbonisation on your journey 60 times
i think
better than traveling by car so it's a
very exciting project our riding zombies
you know the heart of it has been the
community energy sector
um so just to take it a little bit
further away over in india
um modi and the indian government are
talking about
electrifying all of their railways
and and that's a strategy because india
import all of their oil
and coal
[Music]
so it's important
you know that we we share the knowledge
that we're
we're developing here in the southeast
of england
to influence what's happening
around the world and this is major
decarbonisation
if indian railways can start looking at
powering their railways with renewable
energy which they are
and we're really excited that we've
raised that through riding sunbeams
as a regional strategy and a national
international strategy
so um lots of key opportunities for the
sector cop26 at the moment
peer learning through the community
energy pathways and community energy
sector and obviously the eastern new
energy project as well
i'll share this where you can find
support
so
yeah before we go on to questions mr
chairman
um i'd keep in touch with community
energy south
you can link up with us through our
newsletter join our webinars
or get in contact if you do want to set
up the community energy project
or talk to alex today and do at the
workshop
and we can link you up with other groups
and our mentoring team
so thank you very much thanks for your
patience and listening
hopefully i'll hear from a few of you if
you've got any questions
you manage the technology extremely well
thank you very much
do do we have any burning questions for
ollie
yeah i didn't know if you can see me or
not so probably that's a benefit anyway
um
since the demise of the feed-in tariff
i can't see the financial viability of
moderate scale solar pv
um can you give an outline of how it
might work please yeah sure no i i've
got that yeah the um
it is so we a lot of our groups are now
raising share offers and are launching
them in line we've got 26.
look the the market at the moment is is
really linked you've got to find
buildings
off takers that have a high energy usage
and um
and also the you know
between 50 and 100 kilowatts really
um but
so do you have a ppa with the energy
user
but we are we are getting
um
share offers i'm seeing community groups
launch projects still
and um
as long as they've got
an organization or a building where it's
got high energy usage you can mix
the direct wire ppa
so where people can actually buy the
power from the solar
then it's still stacking up and the
price of panels are also reducing
so um
it's very much working still and look at
what's happened to the price of power
over
over the last
month so um
and it would be good to get to a stage
with households
where we can really make that efficient
for households as well um with community
buying schemes but it's not quite there
yet but larger users
gentle gentleman in the middle i think
in the blue
so if you were
if you're planning a um
a community energy scheme of pv uh what
would the figure of about three and a
half thousand kilowatts per household
per year be the right sort of number
and what would be a typical cost perhaps
would you like to estimate for a 500
kilowatt system ground mounted adjacent
to an 11 000 volt um grid connection
i have to go to my technical teams for
that but um yeah we're looking you know
roughly
a thousand pounds per kilowatt or less
gentlemen at the back to the right
yeah thank you um
a lot of us have been lobbied about the
local energy bill
um how much of a game change would it be
if the the legislation was made to work
for
small-scale energy producers just to add
to that this was discussed at suffolk
county council yesterday afternoon
and
it was cross-party support for the bill
yeah brilliant yeah i mean it will be
fundamental the look
energy bills on off gem are so
complicated now you know it's been built
up with
you know we built the energy market it's
evolved over the last 20 years
with you know covered in regulation and
why can't we
one person
own solar power that they sell to
another so the electricity bill is
really fundamental in all of this
and look at solar farms you know we've
got a solar farm
near near where i have and people always
say to me well why can't i just buy the
solar from there
so i'm really pleased that you've got
behind the electricity bill and
we've got to keep pushing our our
members of parliament and
often on that whole issue and keep
pushing it
i feel confident that we'll get there
thanks ollie if we can um leave it there
thanks very much for your expertise
today and it's nice i think we first
spoke about five years ago and you've
obviously been very successful since
then with the ideas that you were
starting up then so well done
thank you very much yeah thank you and
and sorry i can join in person but
wouldn't want me to because i'm at the
tail end of um of an isolation so
yeah but um i know that alex templeton
and john taylor who i work with very
closely are in are with you
so um you know do catch up with them on
the community energy sector and
and you know get in contact if you've
got any local communities
who want to do this
many thanks ollie thanks for your
excellent input round of applause
you